es sind bilder die schwer zu ertragen
sind in weißrussland geht das regime von
machthaber alexander lukaschenko mit
aller gewalt gegen die zivilbevölkerung
vor zuvor hatte lukaschenko die
präsidentenwahl mutmaßlich aus hoch
gegen seine herausforderin svetlana ich
an oskar verloren
trotzdem ließ lukaschenko sich zum
präsidenten erklären
fernsehbilder zeigen wie regime treue
sicherheitskräfte mit äusserster gewalt
gegen friedliche demonstranten vorgehen
dabei machen sie keinen unterschied
zwischen männern und frauen jungen und
alten sowie aktiven protestlern und
unbeteiligten passanten fast 7000
menschen wurden nach regierungsangaben
seit dem wochenende festgenommen jetzt
kommt heraus die politischen häftlinge
werden in gefängnissen polizeistationen
lagern und kasernen unter unmenschlichen
bedingungen gehalten erniedrigt und
gefoltert fotos zeigen junge männer
offenbar verprügelt mit blauen flecken
am ganzen körper im staatsfernsehen
werden außerdem demonstranten
präsentiert die sich vor der kamera zu
ihrer angeblichen schuld bekennen müssen
ja sind extrem schwere bedingungen unter
den journalisten derzeit in weißrussland
arbeiten wir haben jetzt hier schon für
stunde
fotos gesehen julian röcke bei mir im
studio um etwas mehr herauszulesen aus
diesen fotos auch wenn sie schwer zu
ertragen sind denn es sind nun mal die
einzigen zeugnisse die wir von der
gewalt in weissrussland erhalten julian
lasst uns auf das erste foto gleich
einmal schauen was liest du daraus was
siehst du ja also allgemein muss man
leider erst mal sagen dass das für
journalisten du hast gesagt sehr
schwierig dass wir hatten auch zwei
leute dort bis gestern die mussten
abgezogen werden wurden und werden
wurden unter druck gesetzt heute wurden
die hotels andere journalisten
angegriffen sozusagen oder da wurde
gesucht hat den journalisten die wohnen
auch ausgewiesen wir haben das von ganz
verschiedenen gehört sogar russische
journalisten ausgewiesen
die fotos kommen dann die wir sehen von
von geprügelten von gefolterten männern
in dem fall kommen jetzt von aus open
source quellen also wir müssen mal
wieder ganz frei verlässliche quellen
nehmen oder frei zugängliche quellen
leben von bloggern vor ort nix da steht
jetzt hier darauf auf dem allererste auf
den zweiten bessert nächster ist der ist
ein exil blogger sitzt im warschauer
heute steht beim coachella heißt der und
der versorgt und sozusagen informationen
dem er von seinen landsleuten hat ein
großes netzwerk an oppositionellen diese
dinge sammelt base ist das zweite foto
was wir jetzt hier sehen
das ist der größte und der einzige der
einzige private fernseh kanal von
ausbilder ruß aus weißrussland und das
sind sozusagen hier die quellen die wir
den wir dann in dem fall leider auch
vertrauen müssen weil es eben die
einzigen quellen sind sind diese fotos
belegen für wollte also die fotos an
sich zeigen erstmal nur gefolterte
menschen dann kann man nicht viel sagen
aber wir checken die natürlich gegen das
heißt wir gucken uns zum einen an ist
dieses foto neue hat es schon mal
existiert oder wo ist es gerade erst
gestern in dem fall ist gestern und
vorgestern überhaupt im netz dann guck
mir an was wurde dazu gesagt was haben
also die quellen gesagt und wir sehen
die beiden männer wollen nicht erkannt
werden aber die haben wir zu aussagen
getätigt nämlich dass sie verprügelt
wurden dass sie in den letzten momenten
letzten moment der 1
zumindest noch mal der polizei flüchten
konnte der andere war sogar in einem
dieser dieser foltergefängnisse drin
das muss natürlich mit vielen anderen
aussagen abgleichung zu sehen ob die
wirklich nichts sind foltergefängnisse
ist ein stichwort wir haben noch ein
weiteres foto da sieht man so etwas wie
ein lager so etwas wie ein gefängnis
was hörst du aus weißrussland werden
jetzt mittlerweile tatsächlich
gefängnisse gebildet um dort die
oppositionellen zu sammeln zu verhören
also tatsächlich ist es so dass in den
letzten tagen 6800 menschen festgenommen
wurden laut weissrussische
innenministerium alles menschen die
angeblich arbeitslose und kriminelle
sind und eben an massenprotesten
teilgenommen haben einfach zivilisten
die auf der straße waren und wir wissen
dass die mittlerweile nicht nur
polizeistation in kasernen in lager
gebacken werden sondern auch von der von
der steuer abgesetzt werden
genau hier sehen wir solche mutmaßlich
so ein lager oder ganz genau also hier
handle sich nicht um lager sondern eine
polizeiwache oktjabrskaja heißt die ist
in minsk dort haben augenzeugen man
sieht es wirklich gefilmt was dort
passiert also diese berichte die wir
vorher hatten was die menschen
geschlagen worden dass sie geprügelt
wurden nachdem sie ihn gefesselt am
boden lagen
die bestätigen sich hier den text termez
leider nicht glaube ich aber wir wissen
dass die die menschen jetzt sagen wir
waren doch auf die auf dieser
demonstration den menschen ist das
passiert dort hoffentlich passiert dass
uns nicht auch wie sieht es
grundsätzlich aus wie sieht die
situation grundsätzlich aus in
weißrussland die proteste sind die nach
wie vor da ist nach wie vor die
oppositionsbewegung aktiv wie sieht es
aus oder kann sich der langzeit
präsident lukaschenko doch im amt halten
und jetzt einfach ja praktisch
festhalten an der macht und weitermachen
also der innenminister von weißrussland
hat heute damit geprahlt dass die
proteste schwächer geworden seien
gestern und dass man kurz davor sei auch
diese bewegung zu beenden in der
wirklichkeit sieht es anders aus wir
haben heute gesehen dass in zahlreichen
städten alle großen unternehmen
bestreikt haben und zwar staatlicher
unternehmen
also die dann beispielsweise traktoren
bauen oder die margarine herstellen also
da kommt 100 frauen beispielsweise die
margarine herstellen wir sehen auch dass
in immer mehr städten demonstranten auf
der straße sind die menschenketten
bilden und interessanterweise und das
ist glaube ich wirklich ein großes
problem für das regime
wir sehen immer mehr soldaten die sich
auch sympathisieren mit den menschen die
also entweder in blumenreichen haben wir
vorher gesehen oder aus ihren praxen den
sieg eingefahren werden in die städte
heimlich das victory-zeichen machen oder
das herz zeichen oder eben diese faust
die drei zeichen von den drei frauen und
ich muss nur einem land ist die diese
oppositionsbewegung anführen